[Music]
America is now the epicenter of the
corona virus pandemic America has passed
the grim milestone of twenty thousand
five hundred deaths to overtake Italy as
the world's worst hip nation many blamed
the president for the scale of the
crisis these are the lonely times for a
president all the decisions come to you
and he's made just about all of them
wrong but the causes of America's
failings in dealing with the virus run
far deeper independent of Donald Trump
America is a country that always would
have found fighting a pandemic to be
difficult regardless of who the
president was when the novel coronavirus
hits America President Donald Trump's
administration was slow to act early on
the president was you know reassuring
Americans that things will not get so
bad we have it very much under control
you seem to be worried about the stock
market and it's vacillations
and I think that there was a series of
critical weeks in which the threat was
was underplayed the administration's
initial complacency was set to store up
problems for the weeks ahead there was a
sense that we didn't need to develop the
amount of ventilators that we had the
number of personal protective equipment
that could go out to doctors and what we
find now is that we're in the midst of a
national shortage of those things on
March 9th the Trump administration
promised millions of test kits crucial
to monitor the spread of the virus yet
by the end of the month only around
200,000 tests have been
completed this is a serious thing and
right now the federal government is
failing but this failure wasn't entirely
down to president Trump's inaction
thousands of Americans may have been
exposed to the corona virus but have not
been tested the first tests created by
the Centers for Disease Control a
federal agency didn't work
private and academic labs around the
country tried to develop their own tests
but were initially hampered by strict
regulations and a laborious approval
process that's a technical failing and a
bureaucratic failing that perhaps could
be laid on the president but one of the
things about America is that Public
Health Authority is incredibly devolved
to states and cities in terms of how
they respond so that the federal
government actually can't order these
things America's federal system grant
states the authority to decide when and
how to respond in a public health crisis
like this pandemic and every state has
responded differently the states 19
million residents are being told to stay
at home as much as possible
faced with an escalating crisis the
governor of New York announced a
statewide lockdown on March 20th we're
going to put out an executive order
today New York State on pause we need
everyone to be safe otherwise no one can
be safe on the same day in Florida
Spring Breakers were reveling on beaches
I get Colonna I get Corona at the end of
the day I'm not gonna let it stop me
from partying here there would be no
lockdown for almost another two weeks
during which time the virus continued to
spread across the country some states
called for non-essential businesses to
be closed and for people to stay at home
much earlier than others the fact that
borders remain open between the states
complicates efforts at containment while
some states might have kind of shut down
at this time you know California
Washington Oregon for residents from
there goes Florida that comes back you
can see how it could exponentiate from
there that's the weakness of a system
that relies on decision makers in 50
states and numerous jurisdictions a
virus doesn't respect state lines
in efforts to hope the spread of the
virus have been impeded by another
aspect of America's political system
Democrats what do they do they want to
use a deadly virus as a political weapon
against the president partisan politics
are crippling America's response to the
corona virus pandemic politics has
infected America's handling of the
outbreak Republican and right leading
politicians have been slower to impose
restrictions than Democrats I am
pleading with you to stay home stay home
unless it is necessary for you to go out
part of the reason that is that it
starts in the city so it's taken off in
places like New York and Seattle and
California and these are places that
tend to have Democratic mayor's tend
have Democratic governors when political
scientists kind of try and account for
the rate of infection how rural your
state is and all the rest they still see
that Republican governors are slower to
implement social distancing measures
there's even evidence that Americans
adherence to the rules crucial to
halting the spread of the virus is also
being influenced by party loyalty you
see at least from what we can measure
from cell phone data Republicans seeming
to take social distancing less seriously
than Democrats
this blanket spread of shutting down
businesses that's an
disaster for Michigan and people are
sick and tired of it
GPS data show that Democratic voters in
the 2016 presidential election have cut
traveled more than Republican voters in
Hawaii where the majority voted Democrat
in 2016
people more than half their travel in
March in Wyoming where the majority
voted Republican travel actually
increased slightly is supremely
unhelpful for response to a virus to be
politically polarized because the virus
obviously infects whomever can on April
11th America overtook Italy to become
the worst hit country in the world the
damage the virus is causing in America
is compounded by the nature of its
health care system American hospitals
are a business much more so than that in
other parts of the world there's no
financial incentive for hospitals to
have extra beds in the ICU or extra
ventilators or extra pulmonologist
Tuscon specialize in intubation only 305
of America's 6,000 or so hospitals offer
the most intensive treatment available
that's if patients even make it to
hospital roughly 12% of Americans don't
have health insurance around 23 percent
of those who do have insurance are
underinsured which means they could be
hit with high charges more than half of
working-age people have health insurance
through their employers but now with
over 20 million Americans claiming
unemployment many may lose that access
if you're more people afraid of getting
treatment then you know the mortality
rate might be higher than it ought to be
all of those things mean that a pandemic
would have strained the American
healthcare system quite a lot no matter
who was president
the Trump administration has promised
some help to those who don't have access
to health care today I can so proudly
announce that hospitals and health care
providers treating uninsured corona
virus patients will be reimbursed by the
federal government using funds from the
economic relief package Congress passed
last month yet there are still a lot of
unanswered questions about exactly what
and who is covered by the federal fund
for much of America the peak of the
corona virus pandemic is not yet in
sight on April 16th president Trump
presented a set of guidelines on how and
when social distancing measures could be
lifted he made it clear that the next
move is up to each individual state
every state is very different they need
to remain close we will allow them to do
that and if they believe it is time to
reopen we will provide them the freedom
and guidance to accomplish that task yet
the president immediately undermined his
own guidelines by showing support for a
growing protest movement demanding an
end to lock downs these are people
expressing their views I see where they
are and I see the way they're working
but they seem to be very responsible
people to make
Donald Trump has presided over and done
much to encourage America's disjointed
response to the pandemic the combination
of an erratic president federalized
government and a complex and fragmented
healthcare system means America's
already high death toll will continue to
mount
I'm madri's Kalu I'm the US policy
correspondent for The Economist I've
been writing about how coronavirus has
been affecting Americans of all stripes
if you want to read more of our coverage
you can see the link beside me
[Music]
you